the movie is huby halloween it'll be
released
on netflix next wednesday october 7th
and my co-star adam sandler joining
me on the program good morning sandman
it's already a hit
it's already a big hit how do you know i
just got it
you get a feeling it's it's when i have
a
hit uh coming i walk differently i got a
little uh the bones feel better the i
hear better
uh i react better to like hey sandman on
the street i'll go
hey what's up when i got something
coming out that's not going to do well
there's the bones feel dead there's no
hop i'm flat-footed
i hear hey sandman i do this like no
you know it's a hit uh you got a beard
on for those who are
listening on the radio is uh is this
quarantine
or is this uh for the next movie next
movie beard
uh but it it it's pretty it's
it's i'm getting used to it you did you
ever grow a full
uh what goes on with you no nothing
can you uh probably not
i never knew i could until this this
moment but you seem kind of hairy
no there's no hair on my body none
except on my oh my eyebrows
prove it take off your shirt
you gotta give me six months
but when you did when you did uh longest
yard
that you had to get in football shape is
that as good
of shape as you've been in in a movie
best shape was zohan
zohan ooh i was running six
six miles a day like you you crazy man
how far do you run with no no i don't
run anymore i just do
i do cycling i bike does that hurt the
knees at all
uh it depends but um it it's a lot
better on them than running six miles
let's put it that way you know what i
bought yesterday
uh the the mirror the mirror exercise
thing
for 45 minutes like you're going to sign
up for a class where you just look at
yourself
and coach the trainer is going to go
come on you got to do something
no i wanted i bought that thing i wanted
to see it look like fun
um all right so the movie is uh coming
out next wednesday
let me uh give people an idea what this
is all about
this is uh the red i do sound effects
while you're talking can i do like music
behind you while you're discussing it
like
okay all right hold on hold on here okay
you ready
hubie du dubois adam sandler thanklessly
spends every halloween making sure the
residents of his hometown
salem celebrate safely and play by the
rules
but this year an escaped criminal and a
mysterious new neighbor
have hubi on high alert when people
start disappearing it's up to huby to
convince the police
and townsfolk that the monsters are real
and only he can save them qb halloween
will be released on netflix next
wednesday october 7th
he's gonna get you he's gonna get you
yeah yep that's gonna be fun man that
movie's just pure fun i can't
i can't did you get to see the whole
thing or only your part only my part
in fact let me play the part uh for
people on
uh if you're watching on peacock you get
to see it but if you're listening on
radio
this is the scene part of the scene that
i'm in with adam sandler and hubie
halloween
here again to talk about halloween
safety is
salem's official volunteer halloween
helper
[Music]
oh god
hello webster elementary school i am not
a ghost
but i play one on tv uh-huh
just plain my name is hubie dubois and i
am here to tell you that halloween is
fun
but we must stay out of the danger zone
and then right after that chaos ensues
that was the best remember first couple
of takes you would say it quietly and i
said
danny boy let the room hear you man i
know and then
but you always let me have a little bit
of room there where i i get to yell out
he's a human being oh my god that was my
favorite man i love that i love that and
then that was quite a food fight yes it
was oh i didn't i didn't want to give it
away
oh okay no food fight no food okay yeah
so it could be a food fight and then i
got to the point where
i just thought and you always do a
number of takes so i started grabbing
food
and throwing at you when you were trying
to get out of the room so
a lot of fun some of the people in it uh
let's see you got uh julie bowen
you got ray liotta you got michael
chiklis uh maya rudolph
and uh kevin james uh rob schneider
liam neeson uh ryan reynolds
[Laughter]
daniel day lewis you got him in here too
he came back for this one
if you're gonna come back for a roll
this would be the roll
danny boy plays the uh cafeteria lady
and and
i appreciate him showing up and doing
that no i'm a principal no i meant danny
day-lewis oh daniel daley oh i thought
you meant me yeah so i'm
you're the principal of the school and
you were very nice to hubie
to tell the that i was a human being and
for everyone to be nicer to me i
appreciate that
uh so uh let me see this comes out next
wednesday
and now there's a couple things i need
to bring up
first of all you have a surprise for one
of the danettes
and you have a story about your aunt and
joe namath
yeah i'm sure my uncle michael's
listening right okay so let's
let's do the ant story so when i i heard
you on kimmel
and you started to tell the story and
then when i talked to
what was it last night or the night
before and i said
you have to bring up the story about
your aunt and
so when is this when your aunt meets or
hooks up with joe namath
uh well this was i was a kid um
my i was probably like
seven or eight and um my uncle
uh was very close with my aunt they were
married and madly in love
and they were open about everything and
uncle michael was so
carefree about it he's like bobby you
dated uh
joe namath before we started dating and
we were all like
you met joe nabith and he's like no
dated him dated him
so we were like oh my god and so my
uncle
literally he bought me and my brother's
got two number 12 sweatshirts and we
used to wear nameth
and he was like yeah we always pulled
for namith and then as an old
man i was like boy my uncle was kind of
cool about
when my aunt's passed i would be
steaming i'd be steaming every day if
if jackie was said to me right before
by the way me and joe namath we had it
going on
[Laughter]
how would you feel though if you found
out your wife dated tom brady
i would get it i would get it there's a
yeah i would say i'd say you should
we should raise we should have raised
that kid we should
you ever talk to joe namath about your
aunt i don't
think so i met david one time i probably
that's all that was going through my
head
but but honestly my uncle was my uncle's
six
six and he he looked a little like joe
namath and so
people when he would visit new hampshire
they'd come up to him and he was like a
big
athletic dude and they'd be like are you
he go
joe namath no i'm not but my wife
dated i like did you watch your jets
last night
i watched uh for a while and uh i got
and i then i i had work to do i
felt it going i was getting texts from a
friend of mine who likes the raiders
and kept saying god dude would you
please be
denver for us and and i wasn't going
right huh
would you ever want to buy a team or be
part of a group
i think about that sometimes but then
it's like not fun at all you're just
a nervous wreck first of all i i i
wouldn't be able to
tell the players what i think is going
on i like i like the players too much i
get too excited
i i wouldn't be able to say like we got
to do this this and that i would
i would be like hey man leave the guys
alone they're working hard
so no no i mean i it would be
maybe 20 years ago i used to think like
that now i just get i
i just like watching the teams he's adam
sandler the movie is huby halloween
it'll be coming out on netflix
next wednesday october 7th and uh oh
what's the rating on this
it's probably pg-13 it's like the uh
grown-ups it's like grown-ups you know
it's supposed to be for everybody and
it's by me it's a little
couple of things in there that uh your
real young kids will get
say what did that mean but that's pretty
pretty friendly
so my nude scene stays in or is it out
yeah yeah we shot at the proper angle
just at home for the home viewers we got
danny at the proper angle you just
you feel the shadow
uh do you have the surprise for one of
the danettes that you would like to
reveal right now
first of all i love all of the nets and
you're all invited
uh my uh and danny you're in the in the
i'm asking you to be in the movie also
you and
three of the danettes will be in one
scene and then
uh because it's a philly story me and
locker and were discussing this uh
i said how about uh mclovin is is more
of a
uh he's a philly boy and he knows his
feel and it's supposed to be
that a local philadelphia uh reporter
uh is talking to um uh juancho juancho
hernan gomez is the star of the movie
with me from spain
and he's um he he's
uh you don't have to give this story but
it's a basketball movie it's a good
stuff going on for
juancho and whose character's name is bo
cruz and a man by the name of mick lovin
if he says yes asks a few questions to
to me and watcho and he gets he gets he
gets a close-up
the rest of the day nets kind of just
get a watch so mclovin
um is this an official offer to mclovin
this is an official offer uh okay
now this is this is speaking role wow
yes okay what what's the answer what
i am so flattered i'm gonna have my
agent call you right after this
interview is done
no no of course are you kidding me
okay i'm so awesome yeah yeah we love
you man ever since you swatted one of my
shots in that little basement we played
in
oh well you're still mad with that guy
called travel on you too yeah you carry
the ball
you travel juancho juancho said he likes
my
game he says i move fan i haven't he he
only saw eclipse
but he says i got i moved nice with the
ball that's not a carry he says that's a
a little old-school cool move he called
no no it's not
it's not you carry the ball you're you
grew up in the catholic league
where the cyo reps were blowing the
whistle constantly
i grew up with men going yeah saying man
do that and and when are we
when are we filming this movie so we
start in philly now
um what the the because of corona
we're doing this crazy thing we're
shooting the non-basketball stuff
for five or six weeks now and then
uh in in august we pick up the rest of
the movie where we the
the guys can have contact and and uh
hopefully life's good by then
and and this is always awkward to bring
up because
i think we did have an agreement after
20 movies i got a car
but i like i don't want to ruin the
surprise but i
i do sometimes have to remind you yeah
so no no no the the the i just have to
do the paperwork and i have to talk to
the
the dealership like what kind of car are
you thinking
would really be symbolic of our
relationship
and all the time and effort and
performances i've given you
so many cars are going through my head
right now um i know you
respect the planet so you don't like gas
guzzlers
but you're you you're you get nervous in
the electric car because there's no
noise and you always need your
noise i do like noise uh i think we're
just gonna go with
we'll go with the chevron we're gonna go
with the chevron okay
i like it it's got a hatchback i believe
and uh it's good for you to store you
know that the danettes in when you guys
go on your road trips
that's awesome when do you want me to
shoot my scene for this new movie
do i have to go to philly or can i stay
here in the man cave
i think i want you to stay in the man
cave to make your life easy
and and we'll send a crew there and
shoot you guys it's it's
it's going to be you uh
um and the fellas so paulie
seton and fritzy are going to be here
with me and we'll show you they get
they get to stay there uh mclovin has to
visit his parents in billy
okay because they'll know he'll be
coming okay right yes mcglovin do i get
uh like my own trailer how does this
work i'm not used to this kind of
starring role
you just well you're they don't make
them your size what are you
you're six five or something right six
four yeah six sports so they don't have
trailers for you but you're
totally welcome to sit in the chevron
the whole time
um sorry i now you're on fallon tonight
oh yeah and i'm gonna record that later
today apparently
some of the everyone's buzzing about how
good i'm gonna do i'm i'm pretty excited
i i think they're right i'll be
excellent
are you going to will you give me a
shout out tonight on
fallon i'm going to let everybody know
yes and i don't understand why you're
not
on imdb
and it's got everybody in there there's
it's got people who aren't even on
camera
and no and i'm not in there yes paulie
adam the
theory is that dan was such a good actor
that imdb didn't realize it was dan
patrick and they weren't sure who it was
oh sometimes the sandman gets threatened
by danny i do i'll put a call in and say
it would be great if you left them off
the imdb
you know i'm disgusted by that because
you are and
you were great how many days did we
shoot that one or two i think it was one
i
i like to get it done uh you know i'm a
one i was a one and done before the one
and done like i just come in
steal the movie and then i leave you
with unbelievable
that day you were so funny and and uh
you do
you belong on the list i would put you
way above
like rob schneider i got to be above rob
schneider
yes yes i'd say about four steps ahead
of schneider would i be ahead of michael
chiklis
no okay uh maybe give it a little bit
more thought
um kevin james
yes i know
i know that that that uh contest has
been around no no no no no
kevin james and i are great now good
good
we are we're great uh steve buscemi
yes you're you're better than
[Laughter]
that is true i put you right right under
leota
leota danny patrick okay and the rest
okay
all right so i'll tune in to fallon
tonight i'll get the kids together
and we'll make sure that we're all
watching and don't
don't let him down like you normally do
okay i'm gonna say your name
does jimmy ever come on your show um
todd is jimmy fallon i don't believe he
has but we uh hope do you have them on
at some point
shut up great on your show that was nice
yeah put in a good word for us for jimmy
fallon
yeah yeah i'll get it all done tonight
and uh but danny
yes i'm very excited for everyone to
watch this halloween movie halloween is
a little odd this year
and uh this movie is a full-on comedy
but it's in a slightly scary
uh as so uh kids who watch it might get
a little nervous but they'll be able to
power through it man
it's actually like a nice thing because
my daughters can't stand
scary movies they run out of the room
and all that stuff and this they feel
brave because they make it through the
scary moments
hubie halloween released on netflix of
course
wednesday october 7th san mateo danny
thank you
before i go when you're sitting when
you're sitting yes
is it possible for your stomach to look
good at this age
just standing standing you can get away
with it sitting it's terrible
yeah yeah so even if you don't really
have a gut
you still create not saying you have a
gut
right but you may give the appearance
that you have a gut
it's terrible because i used to sit and
put my socks on and be so excited how
great it looked
and now now i tend to lay down
okay thank you sam man miss you buddy
thank you for everything everybody
that's adam sandler got an official
movie role for mclovin
and the danettes as well qb halloween
next wednesday on netflix